[Music]
hi I'm Trini and this is my glamour 24/7
good morning
highs of skin fresh cleanser aside
portion of a 4-year to get in there
answered the shower and now I'm gonna
use the whole body pads which are for
your body this Lily hi Lily say hi
properly Kenny what you want to bark at
the door I'm going with my audience good
morning everybody how are you this
morning we are doing your favorite masks
when you know the thing is sometimes I
think the mass makes me look better than
no masks at all because it cut
you know just covers the [ __ ] so the
amount of time I do lives in a mask is
because underneath like to think like
[ __ ] just say hello to glamour glamour
magazine say hello there she is with a
lovely mask on she's an ER and I doing a
live talking about body shape and
talking about our old book and I can
only find a copy in Polish I'm here with
Trini London face book with all these
lovely ladies and we're just doing a
summer makeup routine here I am but a
large number of the Trini tribe and we
are doing a virtual launch of indie and
they are being magnificent so ladies say
hi to Glamour
cauliflower cheese with a bit of a
chicken sausage so good so good
um I watch University Challenge every
night I'm back to series 2013 now and I
get between five and six in each one but
I kind of it challenges my brain and
when we were going down into staying
safely at home I really wanted to like
do a university course or something
thinking oh I have all the time in the
world
in fact I've had less time now than I've
ever had to do things by myself so
that's my little stimulate the brain
moment I mean walking when I go back
into work is an outfit to me of giving
me an ageless hippie-dippie feeling cold
and then I just did a tiny bit on my eye
I just decided to do a sophisticated
smokey eye and then I did a little bit
of Maddy on top of Freddie for my lips
so the makeup is kind of you know a
little bit saucy because you want that
slight smokiness when you're doing this
kind of sexy look and I just love your
boots I can tell you I love it and when
I first saw this I just thought I won't
be able to wear this sort of mint green
but now with with all these colors and I
thought I couldn't wear the champagne
but then with the secret not apply it
works so it's amazing how if you are
tenacious how you can get your clothing
to work for you with a little help from
makeup jewelry and patience
[Music]
thanks for watching hope you enjoyed it